daran good morning thanks for joining us
explain to me what Vince McMahon is
doing with the hundred million dollars
worth of WWE shares that he cashed in
morning Dan thanks for having me a
report about a week ago actually on
Deadspin about the fact that Vince
McMahon's or the WWE's lawyer was
associated with a company called alpha
entertainment through a trademark filing
for you are FL which people thought
would be ultimate reality football
league and so you know I was just
sitting on this to see hey you know
what's going on is this man doing
something and yesterday the WWE as they
have to do they filed a filing with the
Securities Exchange Commission saying
that Vince McMahon was selling a hundred
million dollars worth of shares to fund
alpha entertainment which was the
company on that original trademark
filing and that one of its goals was
professional football now whether that
is he wants to buy a NFL team or not
that's what was the next step for me or
is it XFL to then hours later on the US
Patent and Trademark Office alpha
entertainment it came up it takes a
couple days after these filings happen
alpha entertainment filed for five
trademarks to XSL so that kind of you
put it all together and you're saying
wow he it looks like he's really gonna
do this thing again
what can you can it work now how does it
work differently than it makes they
failed last time well okay so I think
it's gonna have to either be gimmick or
football and he has to choose if it
can't just be a lot of gimmicks with
some football that either has to be all
gimmick which is basically wrestling you
know that he draws out the plays he
determines who wins he hires a mix of
athletes and actors and makes it a live
drama or he actually competes with
NFL for tower and when I say competes
because it's got to be good football
it's not like the USFL in the early 80s
where they if they just beat out the NFL
money guy like Herschel Walker wasn't
close but you know Steve Young it wasn't
close but sometimes they just beat him
out in the USFL got it he would have to
pay three to five times and I felt would
pay some of these guys and maybe he
could because they'd be blackballed
potentially they might never go back in
they the obviously your NFL dream
whatever XSL to is it's not necessarily
the dream if you want to do real
football he's gonna have to have the
some of the gimmicky guys whose weren't
given a chance but it can't be all them
it could be Tebow and Manziel but it's
also got to be I don't know someone
who's pretty good who's still in the
prime of their career if you want it to
be football all right let me throw this
out though what if Vince McMahon is
cashing in this kind of money because
he's gonna make a run at the Carolina
Panthers could be they the only thing
the only thing I had was that obviously
he has this alpha entertainment maybe
it's one big red herring and he needs to
you know keep people away obviously if
we if we knew that he was a bitter and
an NFL team that could drive up a price
maybe the whole XFL filings are you know
again red herring but it seems like it's
it's a second shot at this week now if
he starts the Trump football we also
know he's close to Trump if he you know
points out hey everyone please stand for
the national anthem thank you obviously
Kaepernick's not getting the job in that
week but there would be a reason for him
to say nothing to see here you know and
keep people away from if he is bidding
for an NFL team because you know maybe
you could lose a couple hundred million
dollars if you know that Vince McMahon
is bidding it ratchet up the price yeah
I'm just kind of curious with this that
so McMahon has not said anything on the
record here with this nothing all right
well I appreciate your time Darren
thanks for
joining us I know you'll stay on the
case you got it God son you're dead you
- daran daran Ravel has been sports
business reporter there for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]